et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc patrick kanner bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec le sénateur
du nord président du groupe socialiste
ici au sénat et on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et votre presse régional la
voix du nord bonjour moi
bonjour vive la voix de nos jours
monsieur le sénateur
par la crise patrick kanner puisque vous
l'avez vu les députés ont donc voté
cette nuit la loi qui prolonge le pass
sanitaire jusqu'au 31 juillet vote de
justesse un d'ailleurs seulement 10 voix
d'écart entre les pour et les contre et
notamment cet amendement qui a été
adoptée les chefs d'établissements
scolaires qui pourront savoir quels
élèves sont vaccinés ont pas c'est une
bonne mesure pour ça me paraît pas être
le rôle d'un chai talisman que de
commencer à contrôler la situation
sanitaire des des enfants
sur les onze vaccins obligatoires
là on peut parce que il pour entrer à
l'école il faut être vaccinés avec ses
onze vaccin obligatoire depuis
maintenant quelques années sur cette
opération je suis très très réservé et
donc ça viendra au sénat on va analyser
les conditions l'exposé des motifs de
cet amendement qui est passé cette nuit
forcément contre
je crois qu'il faut investiguer mais
très honnêtement encore une fois le
parce que c'est le rôle d'un enseignant
d'un chef d'établissement est bien de
commencer à vérifier finalement le
portable le d'un enfant de six ans qui
ne va pas je suis perplexe et sur le
principe de la cette prolongation
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 je suis contre
je suis content pour vous et du contrôle
sanitaire secousse avec notre solution
n'est pas celle là c'est le magasin un
victoire on y reviendra mais il est hors
de question de permettre pour reprendre
l'expression de gérard larcher mais que
j'avais aussi utiliser de donner un
blanc seing au gouvernement jusqu'au 31
juillet après les élections
présidentielle et législatives ça sera
quoi la position du groupe socialiste en
fin de semaine prochaine ça veut dire on
va jouer en février c'est la position de
m autour des oriels où on voit deux
contres au delà du 15 novembre votre
compte ou votre compte on a voté contre
10 juillet puisque on considère c'est un
pis-aller que c'est une manière de
procrastiner de reporter la décision
pour le gouvernement
et que les chiffres aujourd'hui même
s'ils ne sont pas aussi terrible qu'il
ya quelques mois montre quand même qu'à
une reprise de l'épidémie et si demain
il ya un nouveau variant pendant l'hiver
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc nous on est
bête et discipliné entre guillemets
peut-être diront certains mais on croit
la vaccination têtu et têtu donc puisque
vous risquez de relancer cette question
de la vaccination obligatoire bien sûr
il y aura il y aura des amendements en
ce sens on va aller jusqu'au bout c'est
seulement une cohérence la cohérence et
que la liberté individuelle
par rapport à cette situation sanitaire
doit s'arrêter là où commence l'intérêt
général collectif sanitaires et nous
considérons qu'aujourd'hui si on les 8
millions de français à peu près qui ne
sont pas du tout vacciner même pas une
première vaccination eh bien ils font
porter un risque à l'ensemble de la
collectivité nationale et donc je
respecte leur position mais je leur
demande de comprendre qu'à un moment
donné
on peut pas mettre son intérêt personnel
au devant et vous savez les gers idée
par centaines des insultes des injures
des menaces même des menaces de mort par
rapport au texte que j'ai porté comme
premiers signataires sur le maxi nation
obligatoire et beaucoup d'arguments et
était vraiment sur un égoïsme effrénée
en disant mais vous vacciner vous c'est
vous qui allez nous apporter l'immunité
collective mais nous on reste dans notre
cocon pour une partie pas pour tous mais
c'est quand même extrêmement dramatique
c'est l'état de notre société en termes
de compréhension de ce qu'est vivre
vivre en collectif vivre la république à
un mot sur ces menaces vous avez
tout à fait le
on est en tant que là
dès que la wii a enclenché une heure 40
du code de procédure pénale c'est à dire
de dire voilà nous avons eu des menaces
collective le procureur pour l'instant
il en train de rassembler les éléments
mais quelques sénateurs qui ont reçu des
menaces de mort j'aurais pu d'ailleurs
aussi le faire ont déposé plainte trois
petites individuel ouais pas fait ce
sens je voudrais pas fait mais bon mais
je veux dire c'est dans ma tête on a
parlé d'une autre question justement sur
la vaccination obligatoire ça a été
retoqué
contact pour vous vous allez remettre le
débat sur wii en fait remettre le
couvert
[Musique]
déposer des amendements
naturellement
encore une fois est-ce que cet
entêtement est ce que c'est de
l'obstination est-ce que nous sommes
têtus je crois que le combat est juste
rebonds quand on combat politique est
juste il faut le mener jusqu'au bout
exactement autre sujet d'actualité
brûlante c'est la hausse des prix des
carburants à leur premier lille soit
annoncée on va dire cette semaine ou
dans peut-être même dans les prochaines
heures des mesures pour contrer la
flambée des prix entre le chèque est
censée la baisse des taxes dan des taxes
pardon vers quoi penche et vous
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
alors ça on est d'accord plus commander
la corse mais américaine manière
problème il est d'abord là c'est
aujourd'hui si les gens sont en train de
crever exprimant l'expression parce que
le prix de l'énergie est en train de
plomber leur budget c'est parce que
voilà alors budget trop faible il est
trop faible mais lors de comme
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui gagne le smic
donc mis un peu plus de 1200 euros par
mois net il ne vit pas il survit et donc
dès qu'il ya une hausse due de l'essence
une hausse de l'électricité une hausse
du gaz et bien c'est tout son budget et
devient un mail en c'est quoi ces
hausses des hausses des salaires avant
de s'occuper des vrais de la flambée des
prix non il faut s'occuper de la flambée
des prix d'abris parce qu'il faudra que
anne hidalgo soit ils lutteront de
république pour qu'il revienne
vous parlez
dans votre
alors le moi je n'accepte pas qu'un
français qui travaillent qui a un petit
salaire soit obligé de demander l'aumône
finalement à l'état et un chèque envoyé
va qu'une belle l'aide peut-être de
monsieur macro et monsieur le maire dix
ans mais vous êtes dans la difficulté
mais nous vous aurions un chèque
c'est le bonne comme le chèque énergie
c'est le monde c'est le bonne parce que
encore une fois bien sûr ces français de
classe moyenne de de smicards ou de
petits salaires bas ils vont ils vont le
réclamer bien sûr parce que qu'est ce
que voulaient quand on a besoin d'argent
on passe pas à côté de 50 ou 100 euros
one shot quand même une fois pour toutes
donc je les comprends mais la vraie
problématique c'est l'injustice face à
ces hausses c'est une injustice sociale
qui s'aggrave face à ces hausses et donc
nous sommes favorables pour être très
clair tuer des taxes comme nous l'avons
fait sous jospin avec baisse de la tva
c'est ça déjà été bien accueillis pp
flottante éventuellement maintenant
qu'on appelait à l'époque la tlpe est
prêt mais là tu es icp flottant en
l'occurrence beaucoup s'accordent à dire
qu'elle coûtait très cher pour très peu
de résultats un centime et euros de
moins à la pompe 500 millions en moins
dans les caisses de l'état où est passé
le quoi qu'il en coûte tu es mal
continue quoi criant tout c'est
peut-être autre chose une meilleure
efficacité de la mesure juste que je
veux dire par là c'est est ce que la
baisse des taxes ce n'est pas un gros un
outil très dispendieux pour très peu de
résultats alors on va lui parler
d'efficacité
un chèque énergie on peut le ciblé parce
qu'on a on sait qu'il ya un contrat
electric un contrat de gaz
est ce que le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui capable de marquer à une
voiture par rapport à ce futur chèque et
sens la réponse est non et j'ai vu des
commentaires extraordinaire hier dans la
presse y compris la presse régionale que
je salue dix ans mais finalement il ya
des collaborateurs à bercy qui se disent
mais peut-être qu'on enverra un chèque à
des personnes qui n'ont pas de voiture
non mais oh my jeu attendez sur la
baisse de la tva c'est pour tout le
monde c'est pour tout le monde c'est
pour tout le monde y compris pour ceux
qui n'ont pas de voiture pour nathalie
ils ont été en se il est sorti il y
compris pour semer talion d 044
jusqu'à nouvel ordre je pense pas qu'on
achète de l'essence quand on n'a pas de
voiture pour sa tondeuse et enfin
j'étais déçu quand on a les moyens de
s'acheter à chaque les maires oui les
français ils le syli cible mal et donc
moi je préfère une mesure générale
égalitaire qui peut paraître inéquitable
par rapport à ceux qui ont des grosses
voitures oui les gros moyens vous vous
préférez l'égalité et l'équité mme
équipe mais je le temps et ce jusqu'au
bout par pour avoir une plus grande
efficacité et c'est plus clair et et en
plus ça peut être limitée dans le temps
cette mesure donc c'est efficace claire
excusez moi c'est une question qui est
intéressante parce que en effet le
problème de la tcp peu flottante c'était
que l'on baissait en effet mais qu' il y
avait un énorme risque politique à le
relever ensuite et c'est bien ça le
souci c qui prendra ce risque politique
de baisser les taxes puis après de les
relever au moment où les bruits
reprennent leur cours normal monsieur le
maire et ses équipes à bercy n'ont
qu'une seule préoccupation c'est que ça
coûte le moins cher possible à l'état
quand ça coûte cher à l'état pour des
classes supérieures en supprimant lisf
en créant la flat tax sur les revenus
des dividendes ça y'a pas de problème ça
peut coûter cher à l'état par contre
quand il s'est occupé des français moyen
des français qui ont de faibles revenus
des français modestes ou des français
qui sont revenus sociaux et bien là il
ya la banlieue où ils sont radins ses
symboles y place donc c'est un
gouvernement de droite
monsieur le maire et de droite
revendiqué monsieur castex et le droit
de revendiquer monsieur macron ne suis
pas de droite mais il est bon donc ils
sont dans une logique comme celle là et
donc moi je la combat et je défends ce
qu'ils ont besoin aujourd'hui de la
solidarité nationale cette hausse des
prix de l'énergie elle pose la question
de l'indépendance énergétique de notre
ps qui emmanuel macron a eu raison de
remettre un milliard sur le nucléaire
pour vous le nucléaire est
incontournable aujourd'hui dans notre
pays je crois au mix énergétique je
crois aux économies et aux énergies
renouvelables
il faut baisser la part de nucléaire ou
est-ce qu'il faut la maintenir à ce
qu'on pense et je pense qu'il faudra
l'abaisser à terme mais le terminal est
très lointain très droite et je crois
que la souveraineté industrielle passe
par le nucléaire après la question des
déchets est à traiter
la question des nuisances éventuelles la
caisse de la soeur de religion de la
sûreté bien sûr est à traiter donc je
pense que quand on est
comme nous à un groupe politique un
parti de gouvernement bon en reparler je
pense qu'on ne peut pas dire ce qu'ils
faisaient en prise avec le faire en fait
c'est d'eux que vous vous estimez que si
j'en ai un parti de gouvernement il faut
accepter l'idée que le nucléaire perdure
dans le paysage fonctionné c'est une
énergie non carbonées c'est une économie
et une énergie qui pose des problèmes un
par ailleurs où les avez cités mais
c'est le seul moyen moi je je préfère
une
usine nucléaire
a de la multiplication je pense à ma
région oui j'allais vous posez la
question aux éoliennes
[Musique]
il faut passer julienne en tout cas dans
certaines régions comme la mienne c'est
terminé et là je peux partager la vie de
monsieur bertrand pour un quart du parc
saint pierre du parc c'est monstrueux
et mais il ya d'autres énergies
notamment le solaire qui doit se
développer mais tout ceci prendra du
temps et et pendant ce temps le
nucléaire est pour nous un plus par
rapport aux autres pays européens un mot
sur total l'entreprise total qui sont
feu des critiques ces dernières heures
pour avoir minimisé pendant 40 ans les
dangers de ces activités sur le climat
delphine batho demandent une commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale est ce
que vous en demandez une eau saine
c'est un des sujets nous allons décider
de notre commission d' enquête
dans quelques jours au groupe socialiste
où notre mission d'information de la loi
un droit de tirage
exactement je serai le président de la
commission développement durable je
pense que je m'intéresserais à l'idée de
créer au sein de la commission une
commission denquête ad-hoc pour le sénat
mais vous encourager à le faire je ne
vous dis pas cela je nous allons y
travailler mardi de manière collective
vous savez j'ai d'autres projets de
commission denquête très intéressant et
un peu oui
sans parler bien sûr les médias notait
les médias je vois que vous avez suivi
mes propos vous avez raison je pense que
la concentration des médias dans les
mains de quelques personnes voire même
d'un seul homme pour viser vincent
bolloré etc la mesure pose impose un
problème démocratique dans notre pays
vous attendez donc commission sur la
concentration des médias le comment on
comment at-on pu en arriver là est ce
qu'il y à des mesures y compris créative
pour un heavy lois antitrust c'est quoi
ces lois antitrust c'est d'éviter
finalement que tout soit par l'argent
ont remis dans les mains d'un seul homme
quand j'écoute ni mis mon ma radio
préférée après tout lisse et
naturellement
mais qu'on peut écouter sur le
smartphone est heureusement
historiquement j'étais euros par europe
1 voilà voilà c'est mon histoire
personnelle et quand je vois que europe
1 aujourd'hui ses news ousseynou c'est
europe 1 je m'inquiète je m'inquiète sur
la tonalité éditoriale de la chaîne
selec va votre préférence points comme
ils sont en réalité oui parce que on
peut être de droite que de gauche dans
un média mais il faut absolument il faut
absolument que la liberté d'expression
puissent se confronter à celle de
l'autre et quand il ya une concentration
absolue dans les médias et bien fait
qu'une menace pour la liberté
d'expression on va parler de françois wu
président socialiste a sorti un livre
qui s'appelle affronter et dans laquelle
il s'exprime évidemment sur la gauche
alors à gauche dit il dit toutes les
candidatures sont lilliputienne un jeu
de sites elle se livre à des batailles
aussi picrocholines que microscopique
alors c'est dur à dire mais ça peut se
comprendre a plaisir à ces rabelaisien
exactement alors déjà de paris ce que
vous l'avez lu ce livre j'ai commencé à
lire et alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez je trouve ça bien écrit mais ce
qui m'a un peu étonné c'est avec des
mots qui ne sont pas habituelles dans
sous la plume de françois hollande donc
il y a là une acidité une aigreur ou une
cinéphilie tennessee dit et littéraire
intéressante qui montre que françois
hollande est inquiet il est inquiet sur
la situation politique sur la situation
de la gauche il a le droit de l'être
lui-même qu'il a le devoir de nous dire
qu'il est inquiet quand on voit la
situation politique dans notre pays
vous êtes d'accord avec ces propos tout
les candidatures à gauche on est
impuissant pour vous écouter c'est un
constat objectif aujourd'hui mais j'ai
l'antidote gm antidote est l'antidote
chez voilà la gauche sociale-démocrate
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne je
parle pas de la droite qui dans un état
aussi surréaliste la gauche
social-démocrate à une représentante
depuis jeudi dernier ses amygdales go
elle sera confirmée lundi samedi pardon
et
quand je lis les propos de françois
hollande sera l'hidalgo je suis très
rassuré parce qu'il considère
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une candidate
pour porter notre message politique
aujourd'hui c'est un message qui n'est
pas assez entendue alors je lis comme
vous les sondages j'ai dit simplement à
un moment donné la gauche le peuple de
gauche qui est peut-être moins nombreux
qui à une époque peut-être sûrement à 30
30 35 on sent que 30 35 ans sont
aujourd'hui dans notre pays doit savoir
être utile à son
attaque notamment anne hidalgo il dit
qu'il doit retravailler ses propositions
notamment celles sur le doublement
c'était en vo lu tion catégorielles mais
vous allez voir ils compris dans le
discours de ceux de démarrer une
campagne avec françois hollande qui
reste quand même une figure du parti
socialiste
candidatures à gauche les propositions
il a dit qu'il fallait une vision
globale de la société et bien je peux
vous assurer que et j'y travaille avec
d'autres que
les lingots présentera samedi un projet
politique pour le pays basé sur des
choses simples c'est la république
jusqu'au bout y compris notamment avec
l'école pour toutes celles et tous ceux
qui croient encore à l'ascenseur social
républicain
la justice sociale qui a besoin
aujourd'hui d'être réaffirmée et vous
voyez bien qu'on est au bord d'une crise
modèle gilet jaune dans ce pays et la
transition écologique et je vous assure
que je triptyque là c'était un projet
politique qui sera ensuite incarné par
une candidature cette incarnation
s'appelle anne hidalgo combat avec cette
difficulté que en effet vous parlez
d'une d'un lancement de deux campagnes à
lille alors on a peut-être mal observé
mais on nous pour nous il nous semblait
que la campagne elle avait déjà démarré
et depuis mi septembre et depuis
l'université d'été de blois où elle a
été adoubée par la direction du ps
on a quand même un peu l'impression
qu'elle patine cette campagne par
peut-être un manque de d'identification
des propositions d'anne hidalgo et quand
elle en a qui sont qui sont identifiées
elles sont battues en brèche par la
direction même du ps qui qui semble les
minorer comme pour en effet la le
doublement des salaires des professeurs
et puis il ya aussi eu cette proposition
autour des 110 km heure sur les
autoroutes on vient voir ce n'est pas
une proposition le 110 km heure quand
vous lisez bien quand vous écoutez bien
le propos d'anigo elle explique que ça
doit être négocié avec les élus locaux
monsieur l'écuyer comme comme les comme
le doublement des seize voix du nord
c'est bien que quand on veut aller à
dunkerque on commence à 70 km/heure sur
le périphérique de lille on passe après
à 110 jusqu'à armentières
après à 130 jusqu'à l'angle aux environs
de dunkerque donc déjà aujourd'hui la
baisse de la vitesse existe sur
certaines parties d'autoroute donc on
cite polémique pour moi inutile je
m'intéresse beaucoup plus à ce qui
intéresse les français le pouvoir
d'achat le l'accès à l'école la lutte
contre les déserts médicaux
la sûreté sociale au sens large du terme
fait ça qu'elle va porter à lindahl go
et les par rapport à mai du mal à vous
faire entendre être canard dans leurs
sondages sont des sondages mais vous
êtes autour de 5% et une chute de 7%
c'est une alerte je vais pas vous dire
que je suis contente que la go soit
qualité de 5% ce que je vois néanmoins
c'est que la gauche est en confettis et
que j'adorais être un ou deux points de
plus donc la marge d'erreur est que
mélenchon est à lui aussi un ou deux
points de plus fier aussi elle est en
dessous de 2 5% je ne parle pas de
l'extrême gauche oui d'arnaud montebourg
donc cette gauche aux confettis va dans
le mur on est sûr qu'elle va dans le mur
excusez moi mais pour partager le
constat de françois hollande est ce
qu'elle n'est pas ne fais pas comme si
elle avait déjà perdu ces élections
c'est ce que dit françois hollande en
tout cas c'est pas ce que pense hidalgo
peut-être que certains pensent pour elle
mais il peut vous dire que anne hidalgo
et je sais que vous avez pu vous en
rendre compte et déterminés à aller non
pas jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire de
témoigner y compris pour aller au bord
du premier tour non elle est là pour
aller au second tour ça signifie quoi
cela signifie qu'à un moment donné que
six ou sept candidats patrick
je viens de vous le dire si celle-ci
fresco n'y a pas de gauche possible donc
certains doivent se faire avec un ticket
d'entrée un ticket d'entrée qui est qui
sera très bas très bas sera 17 ou 18 %
pour le second tour ce qui veut dire que
et bien la gauche qui représente encore
je l'espère là aussi un espoir pour les
français doit se ressaisir et pour moi
la seule qui est capable de pouvoir
rassemblée cette gauche sociale et
écologique s'appelle anne hidalgo non
pas parce que nous serions des marchés
et gimmicks mais parce que les électeurs
nous ont donné cette responsabilité y
compris aux élections municipales et
départementales
l'ajout d'un candidat disent la même
chose jean luc mélenchon dit est dit
exactement la même chose avec accès
l'envi jt d'avoir le les sondages pour
lui yannick jadot dit que la dynamique
est la force motrice de la gauche c'est
l'écologie désormais comment faire
l'alliance alors
jean luc mélenchon c'est un populisme de
gauche que voilà que je ne partage pas
les sondages ne sont pas bons il est en
train de perdre 10 points par rapport à
son score qu'il a eue résidentiel de
dresser le 2017 il n'a pas de troupes au
plan local nous verrons bien s'il a ses
500 signatures on s'en doutait ah oui
j'en doute puisque fabien roussel est
déterminé à ne pas lui faire de cadeaux
ça ne vous aura pas échappé bon donc ça
va déjà être un petit problème pour jean
luc mélenchon yannick jadot dit c'est
mon tour est fini oui c'est mon tour je
me suis effacé en 2017
il c'est facile pour qui tout d'abord je
le dis je fait un rappel historique
quand il a décidé de s'effacer il
n'avait pas les camps des signatures
pour être candidat derrière benoît hamon
prévoient l'obtenir benoît hamon benoît
hamon a été l'élu entre guillemets d'une
primaire socialiste qui a été plombé par
première ouvert qui a été plombé par
beaucoup de notamment de les fixes
étaient inscrits pour voter contre
vannes pas tout cela est connu et
reconnu benoît hamon n'est pas moi voilà
a été un candidat au nom du ps pas très
longtemps
ni son programme ni sa manière d'être ni
sa campagne pour moi et une campagne
d'un parti social démocrate je le dis
très simplement il a quitté le parti
quelques semaines plus tard pour former
sans parti génération est ce qui est
maintenant le supplétif de élever nos
finalement monsieur jadot s'est retirée
pour quelqu'un qui lui ressemblait
beaucoup et on a raconté votre position
merci patrick amer merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]